leaving the courthouse in cirrus with
his family and two co-defendants
isn't how harry maguire planned on
spending his summer holiday on the greek
islands
the manchester united captain pleaded
not guilty to charges relating to an
alleged street fight on the neighbouring
island of mykonos
but he wasn't in the mood to talk
afterwards harry
harry are you pleased with how that went
did you
did you apologize for what happened on
thursday night harry
you're obviously someone who a lot of
people look up to and respect do you
still feel like you've got that
reputation
harry have you made an apologies for the
call
harry you want to make an apology
are you confident your manchester united
careers still intact
his lawyer was cryptic too about the
hearing which took place in closed court
can we just check what please there will
be no comment
is harry maguire a free man right now go
back to england
what we do know is that the 29 year old
who's paid 190
000 pounds a week began his holiday in
luxury but ended it with two nights in a
police holding cell
it's easy to see the attraction of
mykonos to maguire and several of the
premier league stars who spent their
postseason break there
[Music]
maguire seemed to be enjoying a night
out on thursday
but after this video was recorded police
say he became
involved in a brawl during which
officers were physically and verbally
abused
his case will now be adjourned until
tuesday but the world's most expensive
defender is expected to return to
england and monitor from afar
aside from the criminal charges as he
leaves his greek holiday behind
harry maguire a man previously heralded
for his cool head
will be worrying about what damage this
episode has done
to his reputation among fans and
followers
he'll also be concerned about his place
in the england team
manager gareth southgate is set to
announce his squad for the upcoming
nations league fixtures on tuesday
it could prompt yet more regret for
maguire